myself
and my doctor decide what i do with my
body and medical decisions
not you my employer
impassioned please heated moments on
both sides of the issue as the clark
county school board discussed a vaccine
mandate for all district employees last
night's meeting continued well into the
night with trustees finally coming to a
decision early this morning they voted
5-1 to allow superintendent dr jesus
jarrah to develop a vaccine plan good
afternoon thanks so much for joining us
at four i'm kirsten joyce and i'm
christian casarez with the resolution
passed well the work now begins dr
jarrah says they will bargain with all
of the unions before putting a mandate
in place kate houston spoke to a few
union leaders this afternoon she is live
from the clark county school district
offices to break down what happens next
kate
yes well i spoke to two of the four
unions within the district at this point
they're waiting for a proposal and some
details to go over logistics they would
like to have a meeting with the district
now they say at the end of the day they
don't want to lose any employees because
of this now i spoke to the clark county
education association and the clark
county association of school
administrators and professional
technical employees they both agree that
safety is the top priority and they want
to work with the district on this one of
the concerns though is how the district
will handle discipline jeff horn with
the ccasape says there needs to be due
process and they will be specifically
looking into that when negotiating
starts horn says he would not support
mandating termination if employees are
not vaccinated
it's a personal decision
and we understand that we realize that
and the district is struggling with
staffing now so anything to
cause an exodus of staff would be a
crisis situation for the district so i
know they don't want to go that
direction
part of the bargaining is to come up
with creative solutions ccea president
marie nysis says one possible solution
would be for unvaccinated educators to
do distance education instead of being
inside of the classroom now both unions
expect the timeline for this to be
pushed up but nicest says she wants this
to be done effectively and to not be
rushed she says that the rollout of this
school year has been quote disastrous i
did reach out to the superintendent's
office for an interview they referred me
to dr jarrar's remarks that he made last
night reporting live from the clark
county school district offices kate
houston 8 news now